bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
français ce qu'il faut voir un lien
direct entre ce déplacement du chef de
l'état et les propos qu'a tenus valérie
pécresse la semaine dernière la
candidate à l'est républicain à la
présidentielle qui a promis si elle est
élue de nettoyer les quartiers au
kärcher référence à nicolas sarkozy
absolument il faut il faut voir un lien
et d'ailleurs il faut il ne faut voir
que ce lien ce déplacement est
strictement politique le choix du lieu
tout d'abord le choix de nice nice c'est
symbolique pour deux raisons première
raison parce qu'eric ciotti qui est le
pilier sécurité de valérie pécresse qui
est la personnalité sheller qui avait
explosé et créer la surprise pendant là
le congrès ait l'air est un élu niçois
il en parle d'ailleurs assez assez
souvent et ensuite parce que le maire de
la ville christian estrosi a claqué la
porte deux des républicains après des
appels du pied répétés à emmanuel macron
pendant ces cinq années pour finalement
afficher un soutien ferme et francs
notez que hubert falco qui est le maire
de toulon a également claqué la porte
des républicains était également par
exemple donc on est dans un dé et un
déplacement très très très politique le
chiffre de 15 milliards est à chier qui
avait été évoqué par eric ciotti pour
danser dans son cadre dans le cadre de
son projet donc on est on est presque
dans la copie conforme de ce que propose
valérie pécresse dans un une captive du
parasite politique est alors justement
quel est l'enjeu pour la candidate et
l'air de recycler l'héritage sarkozyste
à l'époque de la sortie de cette petite
phrase sur le kärcher ses propos jugés
outranciers avait été largement dénoncée
propos tenus par celui qui était alors
ministre de l'intérieur nous sommes en
2005 et deux ans plus tard nicolas
sarkozy est élu président oui et ça a
été avec le travailler plus pour gagner
plus les deux piliers de la campagne de
nicolas sarkozy campagne victorieuse en
2007 à noter que
cette petite phrase qui avait fait
beaucoup polémiqué a aussi nui l'image
de nicolas sarkozy parce qu'en réalité
beaucoup pensent que c'est lui même qui
a descendu le kärcher à la cave et que
c'est pour ça qu'il est neuf et donc
aujourd'hui l'utilisation de cette
phrase par valérie pécresse à la fois
parle une partie de son électorat qui
garde une sympathie pour l'époque
sarkozy et puis pour le personnage même
et pour cette volonté vraiment de
ramener de l'ordre dans les rues et puis
en même temps eh bien il se désole de
partie de cet électorat se désole de
l'absence de résultats pendant le
quinquennat sarkozy alors par contraste
les quinquennat hollande et macro aurait
été au niveau sécurité tellement faible
que malgré tout l'image de nicolas
sarkozy et de son époque garde quelques
pas une forme doha une forme de
supériorité et valérie pécresse espère
gagner grâce à cela des points auprès
auprès de son électorat et valérie
pécresse la sueur plein pleinement cet
héritage sarkozyste encore ce matin lors
d'une interview où elle a déclaré
reprendre le flambeau de nicolas sarkozy
je la cite je reprends le flambeau de la
droite d'une droite qui stora
contrairement à emmanuel macron dur avec
les puissants les caïds les voyous qui
va aller les traquer les débusquer et
les punir le kärcher et l'étendard d'une
politique de droite qui ramène à la
sécurité dont les quartiers je vais
reprendre cet étendard et le relever
parce qu'il a été mise à terre ce sont
des propos tenus par un vilain repéré
par valérie pécresse quel regard est ce
que vous portez sur sur ces mots encore
une fois mitigé il y a chez valérie
pécresse une fibre macro nien qu'elle ne
pourra pas renier c'est une c'est une
personne une personnalité politique
d'inspiration plutôt centriste qui s'est
durci depuis depuis plusieurs années en
revanche elle est entourée par des
personnes qui ne débute même des
personnalités politiques parce que pour
certains il ya eu un engagement
politique sérieux donc le premier bien
évidemment eric ciotti inquiets son
lieutenant sécurité mais derrière elle
il ya aussi frédéric péchenard qui
l'ancien dgpn directeur général de la
police nationale ou pendant le
quinquennat
nicolas sarkozy qui est un monsieur
sécurité un commissaire divisionnaire
quelqu'un qui a une formation de
policiers de terrain et puis ensuite on
a aussi l'avocat qui vous demanderez
montbrial qui est un défenseur régulier
récurrent des policiers notamment des
bacs lorsqu'elles sont attaqués donc
elle est entourée par des personnes
extrêmement solide donc toute la
question c'est de savoir quel va être
son positionnement des cannes a été élu
à l'issue du congrès elle a mis à
distance eric ciotti en disant il ya
certaines propositions que je ne
reprendrai pas ça avait créé une
crispation avec lui aujourd'hui il ya un
flou finalement est-ce que c'est la
centriste une fois élu qui va reprendre
le pas et qui va mener une politique
plutôt plutôt souple et puis à la
sarkozyste à dire qu'il ne va pas au
bout du chemin ou est ce que réellement
ce durcissement va va porter ses fruits
il ya une vraie interrogation je ne sais
pas si en terme de communication est
incapable de la tranchée alors sur le
fond des mesures valérie pécresse a
promis 20 mille places de prison
supplémentaires à l'expliquer si vous
voulez mettre hors d'état de nuire les
délinquants il faut réhabiliter les
courtes peines de prison qui ne sont
plus jamais exécuté fin de citation et
de promettre l'ouverture de centres de
détention provisoire dont des bâtiments
désaffectés tout à l'heure emmanuel
macron annoncé la création de 200
brigade de gendarmerie en milieu rural
valérie pécresse a elle promis que le
site des brigades coups de poing et des
de l'armée pour sécuriser la population
est né ce poisson de zones de reconquête
républicaine est ce que vous diriez que
les propositions faites tout à l'heure
par emmanuel macron sont une réponse
aussi à celle faite il ya quelques temps
par valérie pécresse
oui c'est une réponse et il vous aura
pas échappé que c'est une réponse
hémiplégique c'est à dire que quand vous
discutez avec les personnes spécialistes
de sécurité elles vont vous dire deux
choses premièrement la police a besoin
d'être soutenu et pas seulement en force
et en termes budgétaires bien évidemment
le budget important le matériel est
vieillissant il faut employer davantage
de policiers font en maître sur le
terrain il faut les décharger d'une
partie des tâches administratives mais
il faut aussi surtout les soutenir
politiquement ce qui n'a pas été fait
pendant ce quinquennat et ensuite la
faillite de la politique sécuritaire de
n'importe quel gouvernement
c'est la dimension j'ai dit hier
80% des français jugent que la justice
est laxiste et donc il ya bien un moment
besoin de regarder ailleurs que sur
police et gendarmerie pour comprendre
que la sécurité dépend de ce qui se
passe ensuite dans l'exécution des
peines et la valérie pécresse ne s'y est
pas trompé eric ciotti ne s'y était pas
trompé non plus et d'ailleurs quand ils
répondent à vos confrères aujourd'hui
même sur la raison de son nom
déplacement
pour pour rencontrer emmanuel macron
indépendamment de la dimension politique
sur le fond il ne pas que de justice
emmanuel macron ne pas que de police
comme si la question de la sécurité
aujourd'hui c'est une question de police
valérie pécresse l'a bien compris elle
parle de justice la vraie question est
une question judiciaire et non pas
policière merci beaucoup pour votre
regard fredericks anglais je rappelle
que vous êtes politologue éditorialiste
pour valeurs actuelles